not only is Donald Trump having approval
ratings problems he's having trust
problems you probably know about the
approval rating stuff he's been sort of
hovering between 33 and 38 percent
approval depending on the poll a record
low at this point in a president's in a
presidency since polling began but on
the issue of trust there's a new SSRS
CNN poll which looked at how trustworthy
is Donald Trump in the eyes of Americans
and this is the real internal question
from this poll that I'm interested in
only twenty four percent of Americans
say that they trust all or most of what
they hear communicated by the Trump
White House the same poll also shows
weakening in support from Republicans
for Donald Trump that is a key internal
that we've been looking at in this poll
Trump's approval rating among
Republicans is down to 59% I know it's
still to any clear-thinking individual
you say wait 59% of any group supports
Donald Trump that's weird but 59%
support for a Republican president from
Republicans that's also problematic Pat
well I think many of these Trump
supporters are finally coming around to
the idea that this guy is a con artist
even though it's you know nine months
too late since the election yeah because
you know if you voted for him because
you thought he would jail Hillary
Clinton it turns out that was just
something he just said on the campaign
yeah that he would drain the swamp well
now he has Goldman Sachs officials and
finance ears in his cabinet or they
could build the wall with Mexico then he
talks to the Mexican president so that's
not very much of a priority in the words
of George W Bush you fool me you can't
get fooled again and people are getting
fooled again and again and of course
some people will hear these polling data
and say well David this is a fake poll
the pole is wrong just like election
polls were wrong it's been a couple
months since I last debunked that
talking point so I think it's important
to do it every once in a while
especially since not everybody might
have heard that there's a lot of new
people in our audience so the talking
point is you can't trust any approval
poll today because the election polls in
November were so wrong so two points on
this and this is important stuff for
everybody to understand number one
election polls are completely different
from approval polls right pre-election
polls are based on what's called a
likely vote
model we have about fifty percent voter
turnout in the United States so a huge
part of predictive election polling is
who is actually likely to vote because
if you're polling people who aren't
going to vote it doesn't really matter
who they would vote for because they're
not actually going to vote so if someone
says I'm definitely voting is that a
likely voter if someone voted in the
last two elections does that make them a
likely voter that is a big factor when
you look at pre-election polling that is
not a factor in approval polling okay so
not that's number one number two the
pre-election polls weren't wrong point
two a poll that was actually wrong most
polls that you saw before the election
were national popular vote polls and
they were right they mostly had Hillary
Clinton up by about three points Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by about
three points so the pre-election polls
were not wrong now even at the state
level the polls were within the margin
of error Trump squeaked out a win in
states like Wisconsin but it was within
the polling margin of error
there was no huge error by pollsters
pre-election now it may have been wrong
to think every tight race that Obama won
will eventually be won by Hillary sure
that that was a mistake but to argue
that there was a polling error is wrong
that was an analysis error that many
people made ourselves included but the
talking point that the polls were wrong
in 2016 it's just not true and you look
at Real Clear Politics they gave Donald
Trump a 33 percent chance of winning
something like that I mean just because
it's not the majority that doesn't mean
that that can't happen and back to this
particular poll about only twenty four
percent of Americans trusting what comes
out of the Trump White House when only a
quarter of the people in the country
trust you believe what you say that is
going to cause a cascade of problems and
we're already seeing it and we will
likely continue to see it you can
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash re d di t the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to
patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad